john em 1995 essa lata
ela estava em alguma praia de
florianópolis
essa outra é do japão e ela tava em
essas duas garrafas pet com toda certeza
passarão na mesa de algum almoço de
família estavam em alguma praia de
florianópolis skol alguém gosta também
estava em florianópolis
em 1994 um ano mais antiga havaianas as
legítimas
eu uso uma praia de florianópolis kz
coca cola a escola novamente e um suco
de laranja oriental
tudo isso no costão numa areia numa
restinga em alguma praia da nossa ilha
estamos ilhados
é a pergunta conectados ou desconectados
dentro desse saco nós temos aqui o
tranqüilizante de boa parte da população
brasileira não é maconha pessoal
é cigarro isso aqui foi coletado faz
menos de um mês em uma hora de limpeza
de praia na barra da lagoa
alguém conhece espero que dê pra ver não
quero subir ao palco
mas olha só e tem mais aqui pessoal em
uma hora com toda certeza
umas 15 mil xepa de cigarro alguma
criança é fazer um castelinho e um
descuido do país seria inevitável pra
aquela engolisse aquela xepa de cigarro
antes de falar um pouco do projeto ruth
eu vim aqui trazer um pouco da nossa
missão pra isso eu vou pedir para que
todo mundo fique em pé e faça junto
conosco o nosso grito de guerra que nos
conecta com a natureza com a vida e com
o oceano se chama oração do projeto hood
mão esquerda mão direita bem as mãos
sinto a energia da pessoa que está ao
seu lado uma mão por cima da outra
esquerda pode ser por cima da direita
coração sempre acima eu vou falar uma
frase vocês por favor repitam mas com
bastante energia santa natureza cheia de
graça
somos amigos unidos pela raça juntos
levamos uma corrente
mudando que está à nossa frente por um
mundo melhor
tornaremos o último maior ea rota
erguida será sempre seguida é ruim dei
[Aplausos]
galera esse projeto ele mudou minha vida
como vocês sabem aqui em floripa eu
tenho um cargo político mas eu não vim
falar de política e eu vim falar de
essência e principalmente de coração
como um dos fundadores do projeto também
eu posso dizer que se eu tenho uma razão
de viver
a razão se chama projeto rumo ti e
através dele impactar o mundo
positivamente tentando deixá lo melhor
esse é o nosso grande objetivo eu
gostaria de falar pra vocês que a
desinformação ea ausência de consciência
em muitos casos como esses aqui elas
podem transformar nossa realidade e
estão transformando por um jeito muito
pior que o que tem a ver aquela pasta de
dente pessoal
nós estamos poluindo as águas do nosso
oceano através da pia da nossa casa
vocês estão vendo essas bolinhas
pequenininhas aqui na pasta de dente que
prometem deixar o dente de vocês mais
brancos os nossos dentes mais brancos
tudo isso é composto um tubo de oral b
têm três mil micro partículas de
plástico que quando saem da nossa boca e
vai para os canos da cidade e chega numa
estação de tratamento
ele não consegue ser tratado porque a
densidade dessa micro esferas de
plástico com menos de um milímetro de
circunferência
ela é igual à da água então por
decantação são o lodo as fezes descem ea
água teoricamente tratada com um
processo químico volta ao rio
volta uma e o plástico que saiu da nossa
boca vai parar no mar
isso é só uma micro partículas pessoal
do problema
o momento presente nos remete a um
futuro que não é nada bom
não é nada bom mesmo tanto que a onu nos
objetivos de desenvolvimento sustentável
do milênio elencou como prioridade
evitar que a poluição por resíduos
sólidos cheguem aos oceanos
sabem porque pessoal porque no ano de
2030 quando nós fomos pescar tem alguém
aqui que o pai pesca ou alguém da
platéia que pesca favor levante a mão
olha quanta gente pesca aqui a chance
que nós vamos ter de pegar um peixe ou
uma garrafa pet como essa vai ser 50 50
por que em 2030 a cada um quilo de peixe
vai ter um quilo de plástico em 2005 em
2030 perdão em 2050 pessoal vai ter mais
clássico do que peixe
essa é a reflexão que eu trago para
vocês porque com base em dez anos de
trabalho cuidando dos oceanos
eu já presenciei cenas como essa eu já
presenciei cenas como essa onde inúmeros
animais marinhos acabe acabam perdendo a
sua vida ou tendo parte dos seus corpos
mutilados por causa da desinformação e
da ausência de consciência do ser humano
qual a nossa relação com isso
qual a relação das marcas com isso
pessoal todos os dias nós consumimos é
uma garrafa de refrigerante uma lata de
suco uma garrafa de água em um papel de
picolé
todos os dias nós consumimos 60% de toda
a poluição oceânica do lixo humano que
vai parar no oceano vêm das cidades
litorâneas
nós estamos falando e vivendo numa
cidade litorânea
nós somos um mundo litorâneo como era a
pangéia o único continente como os
continentes são hoje grandes ilhas
cercadas por mar
todas as poluições das cidades nas valas
de drenagem um papel de bala que caiu lá
na frente da catedral no centro quando
bateu o vento a chuva ele vai parar no
mar da baía sul algum peixe alguma
tartaruga algum plâncton quando isso
vira uma micro partículas vai ingerir e
vai colocar na nossa cadeia de consumo
hoje nós não conseguimos comprovar que a
nossa querida tainha não se alimenta de
plâncton os que ingeriram plástico e com
isso nós ao acessarmos uma tainha não
estamos comendo plástico
a realidade é dura e precisa de mudança
precisa de atitude e o projeto luti
pessoal assim como tantos outros
projetos inclusive ações voluntárias
sozinhas isoladas elas servem pra evitar
que esse problema cresça mas nós estamos
apenas remediando porque eu tirar o lixo
que está na praia
o crime ambiental também está sendo
cometido por nós porque esse lixo vai
ser enterrado em algum outro lugar ea
lei diz que isso aqui deveria ser
reciclável deveria ser reciclado e nós
estamos considerando que é um rejeito
nós estamos desrespeitando uma lei
federal e nós estamos continuando um
crime ambiental
é preciso pensar além o consumo
quando eu vou comprar uma coca cola eu
quero comprar o líquido que tem dentro
eu quero comprar a garrafa que vem junto
o pacote de bolacha
eu quero comprar biscoito ou eu quero
comprar o papel que vem enrolada em
volta do biscoito
essa é a grande sacada pessoal enquanto
as marcas continuarem não investindo na
logística reversa como era no tempo dos
nossos pais onde pra comprar uma garrafa
de cerveja ou a coca cola do almoço de
domingo tinha que levar um casco de
vidro vazio agora foi transferido por
uma garrafa pet que o custo de produção
é irrisório eo dano ambiental é
gigantesco
nós vamos pescar em 2030 uma garrafa e
um peixe ou um peixe em 2050 e nós vamos
pescar duas garrafas para um peixe e
isso tá normal
a sociedade está aceitando e esse é o
grande erro da nossa sociedade aceitar
nós temos que questionar enquanto as
marcas não investirem em design de
embalagem
nós vamos estar vivenciando esse
processo aqui cada dia se acentuando
mais e mais
o projeto luti essa apresentação seria
feito pelo simão ou pelo márcio gerba
que são os outros dois fundadores do
projecto não puderam estar aqui porque
um foi para o litoral de são paulo
fazer parcerias com outras ongs de lá e
o outro foi para a europa porque o
problema tão grave quanto aqui estão
montando as ações nesses outros lugares
o projeto cresce porque o problema está
crescendo de forma geométrica pessoal
o que eu posso deixar de mensagem para
vocês nós temos um poder na nossa mão
nós vamos escolher o que comprar e aonde
destinar nós temos três tipos de lixo
que são resíduos sólidos ou é orgânico
que o resto de comida pode vir a horta
urbana pode vir para a compostagem para
o minhocário tem várias soluções nós
temos o rejeito que aquilo que não tem
como reciclar num
como comemos então tem que proteger
russo unitário e nós temos os
recicláveis como nós olhamos aqui
a maior parte desse lixo desse resíduo
sólido
ele deveria ter sido reciclado e
reintroduzido na cadeia de consumo de
uma forma correta então o poder que está
na mão de cada um de nós
ele serve para na hora que estivermos de
frente para uma lagoa de supermercado
optarmos por esse ou por esse não apenas
pelo preço mas também pela quantidade de
embalagens que foi utilizada
vamos ser consumidores porque precisamos
consumir
afinal temos que comprar a comida não
temos mais terras para plantar os
centros urbanos as cidades são cinza não
são mais verde
então nós temos que comprar mas na hora
da compra
vamos minimizar nosso impacto na nossa
vida em casa
vamos também minimizar o impacto e
quando fomos à praia paraíso da ilha do
campeche que já foi uma galera já foi à
ilha do campeche
quase uma tonelada e meia de lixo nós
tiramos de lá há dois meses atrás tem
praias pessoal que são inacessíveis
inacessíveis às pessoas e possui mais
lixo que um grande lixão
eu agradeço profundamente a atenção de
todos vocês
convido para conhecer um pouco mais do
trabalho do projeto ruth e mais que isso
venham fazer parte dessa grande mudança
porque só vai acontecer uma sociedade
melhor momento que nós tivemos atitude e
botar a mão na massa para consertar o
problema
meu muito obrigado a todos ea conexão
com atitudes boas é fundamental
obrigado